broadcasting from Jerusalem Democrats
claim they have their smoking gun
Republicans tried to storm a secret
Democratic hearing and congresspeople
prove they know nothing about the
newfangled interwebs I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show the Ben
Shapiro show is sponsored by Express at
VPN protects your online privacy today
at expressvpn comm slash man well first
of all before we even begin I just want
to thank a chat aura for putting us up
in this location this is definitely the
best location we're ever going to have
for the Ben Shapiro show if you don't
subscribe to Ben Shapiro show one of the
reasons you should so you can see the
view behind me because this really is an
astonishing astonishing view has an
amazing view of the Kotel the western
wall is right behind me behind the
western wall you will see this giant
golden dome that of course is the is the
Dome of the rock that's the the Muslim
shrine it's not really a mosque that
they put right on top of the Jewish
holiest site which is what it is the
Temple Mount is behind that wall and
occupies that entire plateau we walked
over there a little bit earlier this
week and then we're kicked off for the
crime of mumbling prayers which
apparently is not allowed formally in
Israel because of the Islamic walk we
wanted to avoid all conflict the H by
the way you should check them out great
organization they teach Jewish wisdom
and values they branches around the
world and you can check them out at
acecomm so again we thank them for
providing us with this slot because it
really is incredible as long as we're up
here I may talk for a few minutes here
about the importance of Jerusalem so
I'll explain that in just one second
first let's talk for a second about your
investment so it's a chaotic world out
there and because there's so much chaos
American domestic politics foreign
politics obviously the Middle East is a
bit of a tinderbox and I say I bet I
mean a large tinderbox well there's a
reason that people are rushing to safe
haven in gold
Gold is currently sitting at a five-year
high I've been telling you for years
that if you are looking to at least
diversify a little bit and keep your
money in a place where it's not going to
be subjected to the whims of governments
that inflate currency it's going to be a
little bit protected from the chaos of
the world well gold would be the place
to go right protect yourself from
inflation from national debt from global
instability if you haven't taken the
first step and actually learned about
all of this gotten your free information
kit on gold you should check out my
friends over at birchgold.com
Birch gold we'll go to work and make
things super simple for you they'll have
a conversation with you you can
determine if precious metals investment
is something you're into
I'm not urging you take all your money
sell your assets and buy gold I'm saying
you should be at least a little bit
diversified I am I trust the people over
at Birch gold to make that happen for
you so go check them out right now over
at birchgold.com text been to 47 47 47
today to see how simple and
straightforward the move can be for you
again that is text Ben - 47 47 47 get
that free information kit okay so let's
say you're not a religious Jew you're
not a religious Christian you're not a
religious Muslim so you're one of the
five people who's not one of those three
things and you are and you're trying to
figure out exactly what is the
significance of that like what was the
significance of this place Jerusalem as
I've said in my book the right side of
history lies at the heart of Western
civilization it lies the heart of
Western civilization because Jerusalem
is the holiest site in Judaism which is
the first monotheistic religions who
really have tremendous impact on the
world and posits some certain central
values that lie at the root of Western
values including human rights the idea
that human beings are made in God's
image the idea that the universe is a
predictable place that human intellect
is capable of understanding you know all
of that is deeply important stuff the
reason that this particular site is very
important is because underneath
according to Jewish thought underneath
the the Dome of the rock over there were
where the where the Holy of Holies used
to stands in the in the beit hamikdash
in the in the temple is the rock where a
bunch of things happen it's the it's the
rock where Abraham according to the
according to Bible was about to
sacrifice Isaac it's also the rock where
Jacob when he was promised the land
I had his dream with the ladder going up
to heaven it's it's a deeply important
place in Jewish spirituality and again
Jewish spirituality lies at the root of
Christian spirituality allowed the root
of Muslim spirituality they're all based
on the same book in the in the original
and Jerusalem is holy to all of those
religions for this specific purpose now
to talk for a second about sort of the
history and geography of Jerusalem
beyond the obvious value of
understanding the heritage of your of
your thought and and then that really is
important whether you are secular or
whether you're religious I was joking
before obviously there are a lot of
secular people around the West and
that's fine you can be a perfectly moral
person and be secular but it is obvious
that you do have to understand the roots
of where your own values come from and
those values do spray
from both Athens Leah the idea of Greek
thought and rationality and from
Jerusalem these idea of faith-based you
have to take it on assumption truths
about the universe that are then
reasoned out through human reason in
this tug and pull between revelation and
reason between faith-based assumptions
that you must make about the universe in
order to create a civilization and human
reason that's what built the West to
talk about the the geography for just a
second you can't really see off to my
left that would be your Dawid if you
could see off to my left what you would
see is that down the hill is the actual
site of the of the kingdom of David so
old Jerusalem which surrounds us here on
my right is actually a much later
invention historically speaking ear
dahveed is the stuff that's 3,500 years
old four thousand years old depending
going all the way back that is now being
uncovered it's now being unearthed by
archaeologists old Jerusalem was built
much later you can see that the the
Kotel the western wall which is by many
thought to be the holiest site in
Judaism that's not true the Temple Mount
is the holiest site in Judaism the the
western wall was actually a retaining
wall for the for the actual platform
upon which the temple stood so it's it's
kind of weird like we're actually
praying at the retaining wall not for
the actual temple itself there was
another wall that surrounded the temple
it's it's sort of like praying at the
fence of a parking lot that contains the
building that you actually care about
right that's that sort of what the Kotel
is the reason that people consider it
supremely holy is because obviously it
is also the closest place that Jews have
had access to for thousands of years to
to pray toward the the point of sort of
the the what they call the Axis Mundi in
Greek the sort of or in Latin the the
center of the the center of the
spiritual universe but the the western
wall itself there's nothing that
differentiates this particular section
of the western wall from the stuff that
is just off to my left which is more
Western Wall and then if you continue
all the way down for thousands and
thousands of feet it continues to be a
western wall is just tons and tons of
western wall going all the way through
the difference is that the mom looks
actually built buildings all the way up
to the western wall so this is all
covered by occupied I don't mean that in
the sense of like military occupation I
mean like people who actually occupy
apartments living up against the western
wall and have store
up against the western wall and then of
course the retaining wall continues all
the way around and all of that is just
as ancient as the western wall here so
there's no particular reason that the
western wall is any more holy
theoretically than the eastern wall or
then the northern wall or then the
southern wall except for sort of
location and the ability of Jews to pray
there now the reason that this is
important I'll get to in just a second
the reason that Jerusalem should remain
unified and has to remain in Israeli
hands I'm going to explain in just a
second because historically speaking
bottom line is you see around me a
thriving City this was not a thriving
city in 1966 in 1966 this was a closed
city the Jordanians were in charge of it
and Jews could not pray at the western
wall all of this was closed to both Jews
and largely to Christians as well and
that changed in 1967 during the six-day
war when Israel was able to take over
the old city of Jerusalem as you can see
when people talk about dividing
Jerusalem they're insane I mean they're
just crazy if you look over to my right
there is no place to draw a line here
none right you can't survive the old
city it is entirely cohesive the
buildings are stacked on top of each
other this is not suburbia okay there's
no big street did an eight-mile in
Detroit right there's not even a
dividing line it's just a giant it's
just a giant well populated area that
stretches for no miles in in in a
particular radius so the idea of drawing
the line and saying on this side of the
line this will belong to the terrorists
Palestinian Authority on this side of
the line will have the Israeli
government which is a free and open
democratic government which allows
people of every religion to vote and to
sit in it and to visit all the holy
sites this wall the Kotel was completely
closed to Jews for years there were
going all the way back to before the
establishment of the State of Israel
when this was British Palestine whenever
you see people by the way talk about
well you know this was Palestine before
was British Palestine before there was
never an independent Muslim State of
Palestine in this area and has never
existed given the way things are going
right now and ever will exist because
there's just no negotiation to be had
with terrorists the bottom line is that
Jews were largely barred from all of the
holy sites in 1967 Israel begs the
Jordanians to stay out of the six-day
war the Jordanians refused they attack
Israel Israel fights back and they
pushed the Jordanians entirely out of
the area leading to the very famous
statement by a member of the Israeli
military haha Bibi a day knew that the
Temple Mount is in our hands and this
has been Israeli territory ever since as
it all we should have been
and as it will remain because the fact
is that there is no dividing line that
can be drawn in Jerusalem whenever
anybody says East Jerusalem is the
Palestinian capital what they're really
talking about is towns that are located
just outside of Jerusalem they're not
talking about like taking this house
right here and saying this is now
Palestinian Authority territory nobody
right left their sensor at Israel and
the left largely doesn't exist because
of this specific issue nobody is
actually going to buy into the idea of
taking razor-wire and then dropping it
right across the center of the Old City
of Jerusalem it's unthinkable it's
unworkable
there was razor wire around the old city
of Jerusalem when the Jordanians ran it
until 1967 it was a complete disaster
area people were not granted access
again for if you're a Christian and you
want to visit holy sites you need Israel
to be in charge of this area if you're a
Jew you certainly need Israel to be in
charge of this area because Jews have
been forbidden to pray at their holy
sites for hundreds of years in many
cases relegated to specific days they
could visit the Western Wall the riots
if Jews would visit these places even
now they're still vestiges of this in
how Israel controls the the Temple Mount
in the sense that Israel still makes
itself subject to the whims of the
Islamic walk so as I learned earlier
this week when I visited the Temple
Mount if you go up there and you mumble
some prayers there's a chance they're
gonna get booted from the Temple Mount
for the great sin of praying in Hebrew
right if I went up there and I prayed in
Arabic then I could walk directly up to
the Dome of the rock I could just hang
out in there all day I mean people
literally do that in fact you can
establish a school there's a school on
the on the northern side of the Temple
Mount where children who are Muslim
actually learn every day if you're a Jew
and you want to walk up there you have
to be guarded by the mission table at a
police band if you if you create if you
commit the terrible terrible sin of
praying up there then perhaps you will
be booted it depends sort of how the
police feel that day if it starts to get
really really bad of it but that is more
a vestige of sort of Jewish Muslim
relations pre-1967 than it is what
exists in Israel currently so in other
words there are more restrictions on
Jews praying in Jerusalem than there are
in Muslims praying in Jerusalem in
Israeli Jerusalem so that gives you a
little bit of the context in which we
sit if you're just looking at the
geography and that's Mount Scopus all
the way in the background this is the
Temple Mount behind me you can see the
Dome of the rock you can see the western
wall slightly below me this is the most
contested area on earth it is also the
area that it is vital
remain
under Israeli control if you actually
wish to see freedom of worship if you
wish to see liberalism and I just mean
freedom and openness then the idea of
handing that over to the terrorist
Palestinian Authority it's a Hamas or to
Islamic Jihad or to any of the myriad
parties who are currently vying for
Palestinian power is full-scale
insanities when you hear people on the
American or European Left say why
doesn't Israel just divide Jerusalem
think about the idea of taking a
terrorist and giving them half your
house and not moving out I mean that's
that is what you are talking about right
here is just unworkable unworkable in
every possible scenario even the left in
Israel has now acknowledged that the the
city of Jerusalem is not going to be
divided as I said before when they talk
about dividing Jerusalem they're really
talking about like the very very
outskirts that are largely Arab areas
over to my over to my left do you see
some Arab towns you know everything in
Israel is very very close together
because Israel is not a very large
country but I think it's important to
actually see it and be here and if you
can't see it at least take a look at
that picture and imagine the idea of a
giant wall a Berlin wall going up you
know half a half what maybe a quarter
mile to my right here great idea great
if by great idea I mean terrible idea
okay now to the news of the day so let's
jump into the news of the day in just
one moment first let's talk about stamps
I know let's say you don't want to drive
to the post office who wants to drive to
the post office a great place right post
office do a lot of great things for you
but you have to take all your packages
you slept them to the post office you
wait in line for years on it and then
finally when you get up to the to the
front you have to take more time working
with something instead you know what you
could do if you go to stamps calm and
just do it all from home stamps.com
brings all the amazing services of the
u.s. post office directly to your
computer whether you're a small office
sending invoices or an online seller
shipping out products even a warehouse
sending thousands of packages a day
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
simply use your computer to print
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send it once your mail is
ready just hand it to your mail carrier
or drop it in a mailbox it is indeed
that simple stamps that comes a no
brainer I mean it really is gonna make
your business easier we use it a daily
wire I use it at home at the Shapiro
compound in the United States right now
my listeners get a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus free
postage ands digital scale no long term
commitment just
stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in
Shapiro that is stamps.com and enter
Shapiro for that special deal okay so
now to the news of the day so the
President of the United States continues
to be under fire over everything
Ukraine related the media are trying to
push back the timeline so to understand
what is happening right here you have to
understand that President Trump
basically suspended aid to Ukraine in
the aftermath of the election of
Ukraine's newly elected leader Vladimir
zalenski and the Ukrainians were not
formally informed of this they started
to get sort of first indications that
the that the United States was holding
back the aid apparently in mid-august
now the media are touting that as an
obvious example of the quid pro quo so
all of this is an outgrowth of that we
have to back up for a second all of this
is an outgrowth of the testimony by
ambassador Bill Taylor who testified in
front of the House Oversight Committee
the Intel committee yesterday and in his
testimony he suggested that he had
worked with a bevy of Trump officials
and that everybody sort of understood
that President Trump wanted Ukraine to
announce investigations and that the aid
would be withheld if the investigations
were not undertaken now the question is
were those investigations motivated by
an attempt to get Joe Biden or are they
motivated by an attempt to quote-unquote
fight corruption the answer probably is
somewhere in the middle okay so and when
I say somewhere in the middle I don't
even really mean like get Joe Biden
fight corruption and it really is that
President Trump you have to think of a
president Trump's character do you think
the president from for the last couple
of years has been deploying Rudy
Giuliani in a specific effort to suss
out Joe Biden and find dirt on Joe Biden
and go get Joe Biden and this was just
the last step of that or was Rudy
Giuliani in Ukraine because President
Trump was really ticked about all of the
talk about Russian interference in the
2016 election he had heard these wild
rumors that Ukraine had Hillary server
he kept hearing that Ukraine had worked
with Hillary Clinton to dig up dirt on
him and Paul Manafort that part app it
happens to be true as reported by
Politico and so in his head when he
heard Ukrainian corruption all of this
melds into one giant ball of mush and
then he was like I'm gonna send Rudy
over there to investigate all of that
and I want Ukraine to go along with all
of it I want Ukraine to simply do what I
want them to do and I'm gonna withhold
aid until they do that now is that to
trump
political benefit is that specifically
about Trump or is that about the
legitimate US interest in finding out
what exactly happened in Ukraine in 2016
now if you say that it can that is both
well then you're in Democrats haratz
worry because the fact is that for two
and a half years we investigated Russian
interference in the 2016 election that
was in the u.s. interest right we do
need to find out if foreign countries
are interfering in the election was it's
a democratic political benefit of course
is that impeachable behavior on part of
Democrats no it's not well if Trump does
the same thing with regard to Ukraine in
other words if Trump has bad information
that Ukraine was interfering in the 2016
election and that Ukraine was attempting
to target him and that Ukraine for some
odd reason has Hillary Clinton's server
and he says I want to investigate every
single bit of that I want all of that
investigated is that in his political
interest sure is that in the interest of
the United States well yeah actually in
the same way that it was in the interest
of the United States to investigate
Russian interference in the American
election so it's hard to see how you can
have it both ways that the Trump Russia
investigation was totally legit
aboveboard indecent but Trump
investigating Ukrainian interference in
was absolutely terrible quid pro quo
solely about Trump quote-unquote getting
his political enemies see I think that
people are sort of assuming a level of
mens rea awe and intent that just never
applies to trump I just don't think from
thinks this way I don't like what is
your evidence that Trump really thinks
ahead and things step by step in logical
fashion toward his end goal but has this
ever happened with President Trump ever
no he's a bundle of reactions and so
he's reacting to people telling him
things he's very angry at Ukraine he's
vindictive about Ukraine he's been told
a lot of stuff by the Infowars crowd and
so he sends over Rudy Giuliani says Rudy
I want you to go investigate Rudy is
whispering in his ear there's bad stuff
happening in Ukraine and Trump's like
we'll get to the bottom of it and we're
gonna withhold aid until they do right
is that is that Trump getting Joe Biden
or is that a quid pro quo that is real
but not illegal and for a a stupid half
stupid purpose but not a bad purpose
right I think that's probably where
things are so one of the points that was
made by me actually and became sort of a
popular talking point on the right is
that during this famous July 25th phone
call between Trump and zalenski
Trump is supposedly pressuring zalenski
to go get your binary mentions Joe Biden
a couple of times and he mentions
Purisima a couple of times and all of
this and the
gyah is that he's withholding military
aid in order pressures olenski and as i
pointed out at the time there was
several reports suggesting that Solinsky
and the ukrainians had no idea at the
time that military aid was actually
being withheld and so it's hard to say
quid pro quo at least over military aid
based on that phone call before the
Ukrainians know there is a pro quo well
now the media are trying to suggest that
no the Ukrainians actually did know that
there was pressure they didn't know that
there was a quid pro quo but they knew
there was pressure and they knew by
mid-august that there was a that there
was military aid that was being withheld
okay well granted they could know by
mid-august but that July 25th phone call
is the crux of this thing and you'll
notice that in the discussions of the
Ukraine phone call one name seems to
sort of have dropped away and that name
is Biden right so originally the entire
story was that this was all about
getting Joe Biden then it sort of
morphed and broaden interval Trump
wanted to investigate Ukraine and that's
bad
well not quite the same thing quid pro
quo for investigating Ukrainian
corruption even badly informed goals by
President Trump that is not the same as
get my domestic political opponent
Jhelum and go after him give me the
information hey that is a slightly
different story now as I've been saying
this now for weeks Rudy Giuliani is
gonna be the one this all comes down to
Rudy is gonna show up and he's gonna
testify and he's gonna have to explain
why the burries Mojo Biden thing fits
into a broader rubric of suppose an
election interference and corruption and
if he can't do that then Trump is gonna
have some troubles if Rudy gets up there
he says of course we were going after
Joe Biden he's our political opponent
why wouldn't we go after Joe Biden well
then Trump is done right but if Rudy
says anything else then this is still
too vague for anybody to to impeach in
the Senate to vote for conviction in the
Senate now with that said Republicans
are between a rock and a hard place a
little bit because Trump's team keeps
going out there and saying dumb stuff
ray of Mick Mulvaney saying things about
quid pro quo you have Rudy going on TV
and saying something ill-informed every
five seconds and so if you're a
Republican in Congress your best bet at
this point is to sort of hold fire and
wait to see more information come out
and that's pretty much precisely what
you are seeing at this point right what
you're seeing is Republicans who are
instead of focusing in on the actual
allegations being made by Democrats
they're focusing in on the process and
frankly that's that's I think somewhat
legitimate so the media are going to
today because House Republicans showed
up to a deposition of a Defense
Department official in what is called
the skiff which is a protected
information room right where
confidential information is being traded
and Republicans showed up and they
started protesting there and they're
very upset because they say not enough
Republicans are being led in now to be
fair there are Republicans who are
sitting in these committees Republicans
are sitting in these committees there
are Republicans and Democrats there
sitting with Adam chef but Republicans
are claiming they're saying we have not
gotten the full transcript we don't know
everything that's being said why does
that matter well because we're hearing
wildly wildly varying reports from these
committees about what exactly is
happening behind closed doors so we see
the full transcript of Bill Taylor's
opening testimony about why he thought
that Trump was performing a quid pro quo
with military aid but then you have
Devin Nunez Devin Nunes who sits on that
committee the representative from
California and he says that Jon Ratliff
who is another representative Republican
representative destroyed Taylor upon
cross-examination and that Taylor
actually could not show a quid pro quo
so here is Newton saying just that but
the truth is is that in two minutes
John Ratcliffe destroyed this witness
there's no quid pro quo in addition it
continues to be alarming to me
the lack of the understanding that the
State Department by the bureaucracy
there about how much the Ukrainians were
involved opposing Donald Trump as a
candidate okay so what exactly happened
behind closed doors the answer is we
don't know and this is what Republicans
are protesting they're saying okay we're
hearing one line from the Republicans
we're in one line from the Democrats and
we're getting selectively out of this
committee so the media have jumped on
Rupp House Republicans showing up and
chanting let us in and saying this is
ridiculous there are Republicans in
there that's really not what Republicans
are question and what Republicans are
questioning is why is all of this done
being done behind closed doors just do
it openly you want to ask questions put
it on TV all right let's see all of the
testimony Democrats say they're hesitant
to do this because they don't want Trump
attacking they don't want Trump going
after witnesses well it seems to me that
doing this out in the open would be a
lot better for the American public
listen I was open that I wanted the
Muller report released okay on the other
side I was a Republican saying I wanted
every iota of the Mulla report released
I wanted the public to see it they had
legit questions and those questions
ought to be answered well the public has
legit questions about this and they
deserve to see all of the answers that
are being given behind closed doors and
for all the talk
confidential information that's being
put out there what like we don't know
what confidential information is being
put out there and I've yet to hear
Democrats even vaguely referred to what
the confidential information is it just
seems like a very convenient excuse to
keep everything fairly closed and that
is that is pretty absurd
so you see Matt Gaetz Oh Matt gets the
Republican from Florida very close Trump
Ally he came out yesterday and he
slammed the Democrats he said that you
know this is this is a shutdown by
Democrats they don't want all the
information out there this was like a
dramatic move it was obviously a
dramatic move by Republicans in order to
get camera attention on all this
Democrats and the media are labeling
this a misdirect effort by Republicans
they don't want to talk about the topics
so instead they're wildly spinning about
the closed-door nature of this yeah
except that if Democrats would comply
with what Republicans wanted there'd be
more information not less information in
the public view so is it a little bit
overblown yeah is it stagecraft
absolutely just gonna point out here
then when Democrats occupied Congress
right they shut down Congress they slept
on the floor of Congress about gun
control a few years back the media
couldn't get enough that Republicans
show up at the skiff and they protest
outside and it's all Republican employer
of course it's a Republican ploy of
course this is Republicans attempting to
gain attention like yes that's what it's
for but does that mean that their basic
complaint is illegitimate no here's Matt
gets making the complaint
I'm gathered here with dozens of my
congressional colleagues underground in
the basement of the Capitol because if
behind those doors they intend to
overturn the results of an American
presidential election we want to know
what's going on and it's only reasonable
that we would have questions because so
far Adam shifts impeachment inquiry has
been marked by secret interviews
selective leaks weird theatrical
performances of transcripts that never
happened and lies about contacts with a
whistleblower okay so the media are very
upset about this according to the New
York Times about two dozen House
Republicans chanting let us in let us in
storm the secure room where a Defense
Department official arrived Wednesday
morning to testify in the impeachment
inquiry refusing to leave in delaying
her testimony for hours there
obstructionist when when Democrats
occupied Congress and sleep overnight
their about gun control that's just them
standing up for a position when
Republicans do this for a few
hours outside a skiff then all of a
sudden it's the end of the world the
lawmakers most of whom do not sit on the
committee's conducting the inquiry and
are therefore not entitled to attend its
hearings said they were protesting the
closed-door nature of the proceedings
which have been open to members of both
parties on the committees that's the key
on the committees and when it comes to
the leaks the leaks have been incredibly
selective Adam Schiff has been very
leaky Adam Schiff is not somebody who
trusted to run this investigation
running this in public view makes a fair
bit of sense the fact that people are
sort of protested like if you are in the
media wouldn't you want more information
in the public view why are you very
upset at Republicans for calling for
more information in the public view
Republicans are hammering Democrats
according to the New York Times for
limiting attendance at the hearings two
members of the Intelligence Judiciary
and Foreign Affairs committees it is
common practice for sensitive
congressional investigations to be
conducted in closed hearings at least in
their preliminary stages
House Republicans did just that when
they controlled the chamber and opened
an inquiry into the 2012 attack on the
US Embassy in Benghazi Libya yeah the
difference was they hadn't announced it
was an impeachment inquiry ad they are
they hadn't come out and said this an
impeachment inquiry they said that we're
looking into the issue if you wanted to
do your preliminary work without
announcing an impeachment inquiry Nancy
Pelosi Republicans wouldn't have a lot
to complain about but you announced this
is now an impeachment inquiry which
means that it should be done out in the
open
Democrats say they plan to hold open
hearings after the committee's finished
opposing witnesses they intend to make
public complete transcripts of witness
testimony after they've been reviewed
for classified materials so we will see
if that's true if that's true then these
complaints are basically a bunch of
nonsense if it is not true then
Democrats are holding this stuff back
for purposes of selective leaking
Democrats are looking to take the
impeachment probe public apparently as
soon as mid-november according to the
Washington Post they say over the past
three weeks a parade of current and
former Trump administration officials
have testified behind closed doors
providing House investigators with a
compelling narrative of President
Trump's campaign to extract political
favors from Ukrainian officials but some
Democrats are feeling pressure to
advance public hearings in the hopes of
avoiding further disruptions which of
course is exactly what they should do
Republicans were very passionate about
all this some of this is performative
for president Trump some of this is
performative for the cameras Steve
Scalise the representative from
Louisiana said sort of the same thing he
said this sort of stuff was commonplace
in the Soviet Union yeah that's over the
top it just is but we'll see you know
look if Democrats continue not to
release any information then maybe it's
not over the top here's Steve Scalise
what is
that of shift trying to hide I think
that's a question so many people have so
many my colleagues have so many people
in the press should have is through
those hidden closed doors over there
Adam Schiff is trying to impeach a
president of the United States behind
closed doors literally trying to
overturn the results of the 2016
election a year before Americans get to
go to the polls to decide who's going to
be the president and frankly it should
be the people of this country who decide
who's gonna be the president not Nancy
Pelosi and not Adam Schiff in secret
behind closed doors
okay so Democrats are certainly feeling
the pressure to go ahead and open the
doors which is a good thing now that
there is an amazing amazing story from
the New York Times today about President
Trump it's called Trump's war on the
deep state turns against him
they say the impeachment inquiry is in
some ways the culmination of a battle
between the president's and the
government institutions he distrusted
and disparaged he's the president of the
United States it is not the job of the
institutions he oversees to undermine
his presidency hey that's not the way
this is supposed to work Trump's whole
complaints about the deep state I was
always honest on the under the
impression that that was overwrought but
it's hard to say it's overwrought when
the New York Times is out there bragging
about the so-called deep state going
after Trump that's not something that
you want from the executive branch you
can see why President Trump is very
upset about all of this now two things
can be true at once it can be true that
there are real open questions as to what
happened in this whole Ukrainian
investigation it can also be true that
the Democrats are partisan hacks and the
only reason they care about this is they
want Trump out it can also be true that
the deep state stuff now appears to be a
lot more real than it did just a few
weeks ago so all these things can
simultaneously be true all the way
through one thing that is not helpful
obviously is the President of the United
States excoriating Republicans who
disagree with him as quote-unquote human
scum like if you are looking for
supporters this is probably not the way
to do this he's presumably referring
here to build Taylor the who is a who
was a trump appointee right it was the
Trump administration who wanted Bill
Taylor involved in Ukraine Trump says
he's never met him yeah but you asked
him to be there dude like you're a
minute like you run your administration
or you don't
Trump tweeted out the never Trump or
Republicans and though unrest paraders
with not many left or in certain ways
worse and more dangerous for our country
than the do-nothing Democrats
watch out for them they are
human scum I mean you might want to
reserve that language for Isis like if
we're gonna go human scum Bill Taylor
the ambassador that you picked for
Ukraine probably it's a little bit much
he said he said never Trump a Republican
John Bellinger represents never Trump or
diplomat bill Taylor who I don't know in
testimony before Congress do nothing
Democrats allow Republicans zero
representation zero due process zero
transparency does anyone think this is
fair even though there was no quid pro
quo I'm sure they would like to try
worse than Thames it would be really
great if the people within the Trump
administration all well-meaning and good
I hope could stop hiring never Trump
errs or worse than the do-nothing
Democrats nothing good will ever come
from them so President Trump is
attributing all of this to bias now does
the bias against Trump exist of course
are there people in the so-called deep
state who despise Trump of course that's
true do we know exactly what Trump did
with Ukraine no are there legit
questions to be asked about Rudy
Giuliani sure are Democrats partisan
hats sure so if you can make sense out
of that you're a better person than I
you know all of these all of this is
sort of a miasma of gross and it's it's
it's sort of mutual poo flinging at this
point Democrats suggesting Trump is
obviously corrupt not totally obvious
but there are questions Trump suggesting
that Democrats are obviously partisan
that's obviously true Republicans
suggesting Democrats are doing all this
behind closed doors that is also true
right now it's it's all a bit of a mess
and by a bit of a mess I mean a very
very large-scale mess now meanwhile the
Democratic side of the aisle is a
similar mass the Democratic side of the
aisle similar mess and we will get to
that in just one second first we must
talk about your legal business okay when
you start a business it's really
challenging and one of the lead costs
that you have when you form your
business is legal writing I spend a lot
of money on lawyers or alternatively you
could just go check out Legal Zoom over
the past 18 years Legal Zoom has helped
more than 2 million business owners get
started every entrepreneurs know it
knows that getting started is just the
beginning of your journey and what
happens along the way will determine
your success that's certainly been true
for our business I've been using Legal
Zoom for legal costs for years long
before they were a sponsor of the
program Legal Zoom now has an
independent network of attorneys and tax
professionals that can help
entrepreneurs get started in turns them
for advice on trademarks and tax law
changes reviewing contracts it helps put
you at an advantage and you saved money
because you're avoiding those insane
hourly fees I know it's
hundreds of thousands of dollars on
legal before just with regard to daily
wire business if you can do it via Legal
Zoom why wouldn't you for a fraction of
the cost go to Legal Zoom calm today
find out all the different ways that can
help your business don't forget to enter
the promo code been in the box at
checkout that's legalzoom.com promo code
been LegalZoom is indeed where life
meets legal go check them out right now
okay so meanwhile the Democratic side of
the aisle is a bit of a mess as well so
there's a reason Democrats are staking a
lot of their hopes on all of this
impeachment stuff and the reason is
because their side of the aisle is a
complete and utter mess as well and so
what you are starting to see there
there's a poll a CNN poll that showed
shockingly that Joe Biden is now popping
back up in the polling why because it
turns out that as people get a second
look at Elizabeth Warren they're not
really loving what they see CNN reports
that Biden now has the support of 34
percent of Democratic and Democratic
leaning registered voters that is his
best showing in cNN polling since just
after his campaigns formally launched on
April 25th so it looked like Elizabeth
Warren was popping up into the lead and
now according to that CNN poll and
several other polls Biden actually seems
to be regaining the lead and widening it
why because he's just default Democrat
right he's a dead guy who's running as a
Democrat he's not even a sentient
creature at this point Joe Biden he's
sort of wandering around bloviating and
nobody knows what he thinks cuz he
doesn't know what he thinks he's
drinking cans have been sure and just
saying words that don't exist in English
and people like that guy not Elizabeth
Warren that guy Elizabeth Warren of
Massachusetts and Bernie Sanders of
Vermont according to CNN are about even
for a second 19% and 16% behind them
mayor Pete Budaj edge and Senator Kamala
Harris of California each have six
percent support Amy Klobuchar and bethe
stuck at 3% each what's happening well
Biden's rise according to CNN is coming
from a consolidation of support among
his core backers who are taking a look
at other candidates and then returning
to him that polling data was collected
from October 17th to 20th during the
hunter Biden news cycle so people are
still seeing him as default Democrat
which is very good news for him and
again the reason for that the Democratic
field is terrible it's a terrible
terrible field right Biden's basic pitch
Biden's basic pitch is that he is Barack
Obama part 3 so Biden came out yesterday
and he says really if you like
everything about the economy you should
you should credit me
with that here is Joe Biden basically
again being default Democrat he is just
he is weekend at Bernie's they stapled
the wig on his head and they're just
wheeling him around on that gurney and
here he is talking about how Trump
inherited the strong economy from him
right now on a under the Republican and
the Trump plan we only reward wealth you
know we had Donald Trump inherited a
strong economy from Barack and me things
were beginning to really move and just
like everything else he's inherited he's
in the midst of squandering it
squandered okay so there is Joe Biden
making his very lackluster pitch but
that lackluster pitch is certainly
better than Elizabeth Warren as you will
see in just one moment first let me talk
about safety and security as you know
when I'm in the United States I have
24/7 security safety is really important
to me I get an awful lot of threats
unfortunately and that is why I rely on
ring and when I'm away from home like
everyone knows right now I'm away from
home
correct right I mean overlooking
Jerusalem I don't live here well that
means that when somebody rings my
doorbell in in LA I know who it is
because it pops up from my phone I can
pick up I can see who it is I can talk
to them I can call the cops if I need to
rings mission is to make neighborhoods
safer you might already know about their
smart video doorbells and cameras that
protect millions of people everywhere
ring helps you stay connected to your
home anywhere in the world so if there's
a package delivery or a surprise visitor
you get an alert you'll be able to see
hear and speak to them all from your
phone it definitely makes me feel safer
makes my wife feel safer as well now as
a subscriber you have a special offer on
a ring welcome kit available right now
at ring comm slash Ben the kit includes
the ring video doorbell two and a chime
Pro that's what you need to start
building that ring of security around at
your home today go to ring comm /ban
again that is ring.com slash pen
additional terms may apply I rely on
ring for safety and if someone who cares
about safety trust me you're going to
want ring on your house as well check
them out at ring.com slash bending in
that's ring comm so I said okay more on
the 2020 Democratic presidential race
which is not quite the Elizabeth Warren
walk over the people were predicting
just a couple of weeks ago in the
aftermath of the latest round of debates
first you're gonna have to go over to
daily wire and subscribe we have all
sorts of goodies for you over there
including our brand new Sunday special
this week's Sunday special features
Preet Bharara now to be fair to Bri we
recorded this before some of the some of
the newest impeachment stuffs we talked
a lot about Muller we talked a lot about
President Trump and legality we talked
about his role
as a as an District Attorney in in
Southern District of New York and the
role of prosecutors I think it's really
fascinating gonna want to go check that
out here's a little bit of what that
sounded like if you're a federal judge
and pissed off the president he tweets
at you and you get to keep your job for
the rest of your life if you're you turn
any pissed off the president you get a
podcast so it's quite quite a different
way of going about it
[Music]
it's really fascinating you're gonna
want to go check it out you can get that
early and get that on on Saturdays
Sundays especially get it early if you
are a subscriber over at daily wire also
The Daily wires long waited app is
finally here and it really is first-rate
if you're a subscriber you can access
all of our contents including articles
shows and more straight from the app all
access subscribers actually get our new
and exclusive discussion features you
can interact directly with me all right
we do these QAS
online they're really a lot of fun the
app is available on Apple and Android so
download today become a subscriber come
join the fun it really is terrific
go subscribe over at daily wire.com for
99 bucks a year you get the magical
tumbler which we brought with us this is
the most holy place this tumbler has
ever been so you can even go check that
out for 99 dollars a year we really
appreciate where the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
already so as I say Joe Biden looking
much better in that CNN poll and one of
the reasons you're looking better is cuz
Elizabeth Warren is looking worse like
the more you see of Elizabeth Warren you
the less you like her as a candidate I
take for example this Elizabeth Warren
she's Hillary 2.0 or maybe she's Hillary
0.5 I don't know remember that famous
tape of Hillary Clinton in in Rapid City
Iowa was it or not or North Dakota I
can't remember she was somewhere in the
Midwest and she is sitting at Cedar
Rapids that sort of was and she says
here I am outside Cedar Rapids chilling
in Cedar Rapids with like a with like a
brew and everybody's like this is the
most fake ridiculous thing I've ever
seen well it was until now
wait until you see Elizabeth Warren hawk
up Waffle House mission work City yoga
studio donated just after the climate
town-hall teacher in Springfield
Massachusetts my favorite if you think
that Elizabeth Warren's favorite place
is Waffle House your high okay really
that is if you truly believe that
Elizabeth she's a woman of the people
every day she goes on over to Waffle
House she has some of those chicken and
waffles and really enjoys herself and
she's a member of the of the waffle
eating pub this is a lady who suggested
that she won't even drink coffee right
her favorite drink was like high-octane
tea because that's who Elizabeth Warren
is yeah I'm sure that she's headed over
to the Waffle House immediately upon the
cessation of her of her latest rally
she's gonna head on over to the Waffle
House and then you look at the other
alternatives you got Cory Booker mr.
Potato Head with the angry eyes talking
about how he's the alternative to Biden
well people looking at him as the
alternative to Biden he's at 2% in the
polls so no that's not a thing so those
Democrats who are looking for an
alternative now I want to make the case
today very directly that look no further
I can and have excited a diverse
coalition of voters I can and have
United progressives and moderates we
need to keep the long view in mind not
just winning a primary but beating Trump
understanding that this is a moral
moment see by excited a diverse
coalition of voters what he means is I
have
I have friends and they're all of
different ethnicities right that's what
he means it means he has a multiracial
very small roomful of supporters which
is very exciting excited a diverse
coalition I love that that's like that
it's it's a pretty spectacular euphemism
like these campaigns are not connecting
with the heart of America right now now
what this is this is why President Trump
really needs to cut out the shenanigans
because the fact is that so long as he
remains top of the headlines Democrats
are going to benefit I mean the polls
right now on impeachment are not good
for President Trump but this Democratic
field is extremely weak plus Hillary
Clinton is waiting in the wings Philippe
Raines who was her chief of staff for
many many years on Fox News last night
and he actually said that Hillary is
explicitly leaving the door open to
jumping back into the race and if you're
Hillary's I've been saying now for for a
week you gotta think to yourself like
why not you think that I like Joe
Biden's it guys like not not Hillary not
this Hillary the country needs him
Hillary and then she's got Tulsi Gabbard
to pick on right Tulsi is going at it
with Hillary Tulsi slammed Hillary again
she put out a new video saying that her
foreign policy was disaster stepped down
from your throne and fight with me it's
funny how when I said that that AOC
should have a discussion slash debate
with me that sexist when Tulsi Gabbard
says that Hillary should step down off
her throne and have it available Tulsi
that's just her being a hard-nosed
politician here is Tulsi going after
Hillary Clinton Hillary Clinton your
foreign policy has been a disaster for
our country and the world it's resulted
in the deaths and injuries of so many of
my brothers and sisters in uniform
devastated entire countries millions of
lives lost it's time for you to
acknowledge the damage that you've
caused and it is long past time for you
to step down from your throne so that
the Democratic Party can lead with a new
foreign policy which will actually be in
the interest of and benefit to the
American people and the world so you
won't know why the Democrats are so
impeachment focused right now take a
look at that field and you tell me why
the Democrats are so impeachment focused
right now by the way how bad is
Elizabeth Warren's campaign and how hard
of the media pushing her there is an
opinion piece in The New York Times
today by a woman named ELISA Court the
author of thoughts and prayers
it's called Elizabeth Warren has a poet
on her team here's why that's a good
idea and the entire thing is about why
you need more poets in politics it says
I don't even know how pronounce this
name so I'm juniper just gonna butcher
it come on hey Felix became the director
of surrogates and strategic
communications for Senator Elizabeth
Warren's presidential campaign in June
she's also the author of build yourself
a boat at Abe you collection of poetry
that was recently included on the long
list for the National Book Award miss
Felix's writings describe sexual assault
first-hand experience of abortion and
police violence including poems about
the trial of George Zimmerman the man
who shot Trayvon Martin should we be
surprised about a link between the
highest levels of our political world
and our most acclaimed poetry I don't
think so and I think we should get ready
for more of it because it's coming and
we need it desperately president Trump
and his cronies alter our language for
the worse renaming white nationalists
the alt-right and calling journalism
fake news so we need more poets more
poets and good luck this is this is how
you win back Michigan right here
you went back those Michigan Auto
Workers by going and getting the lady
who's on the short list for the National
Book Award for writing poems about her
first-hand experience of abortion
perfect well done Elizabeth Warren
campaign I can't imagine why everybody
is so focused on get rid of Trump now
because if we don't we have serious
trouble again meanwhile the Democrats on
Capitol Hill I have to say it's always
amusing to watch members of Congress
question members of big tech the reason
is members of Congress don't know what a
computer is they're still using abacuses
a Bacchae and they are using compute
that they're using like 1984 max because
they don't know what the internet is
they don't know what the internet is for
and so this is what the third time the
mark zuckerberg has testified on the
hill and you got to feel bad for the guy
honestly because when you see the
questions he's being asked it is so
obvious the democrats desperately wants
to take control of the creation that the
Zuckerberg created and use it to control
political rhetoric hey my friend steven
crowder came out with information
suggesting that youtube was actually d
promoting results that was it was
demoting results from Tulsi Gabbard in
moments of great import to the Tulsi
Gabbard campaign if big tech is doing
that I am sure they are doing that at
the best of Democrats who would like to
run this thing from above because when
you hear Democrats questions Zuckerberg
what they want to do with the First
Amendment what they want to do with free
speech and what they want to do with big
tech is truly frightening this is why
when I hear Republicans and they're like
ah the government should take control of
big tech it's like understand that
Elizabeth Warren and AOC are going to be
running that thing it ain't gonna go
well wait what
this example so AOC is just she's been a
horror show in these in these
questioning sessions she used to be good
because she had a guy named psych hot
Chakrabarti who was allegedly writing
all of her questions he's gone so now
she's writing her own questions and
that's sort of like letting actors on
set write their own lines which is just
a huge huge mistake here is aoc
questioning mark zuckerberg asking why
mark zuckerberg would even do business
with the Daily Caller which of course is
a conservative publication she says the
Daily Caller has ties to white knit
white supremacist why would you even
allow Daily Caller on your platform
basically can you explain why you've
named the Daily Caller a publication
white well documented with ties to white
supremacist as an official fact checker
for Facebook congresswoman sure we
actually don't appoint the independent
fact checkers they go through an
independent organization called the
independent fact-checking network that
has a rigorous standard for who they
allow to to serve as a fact checker so
you would say that white supremacists
tied publications meet a rigorous
standard for a fact checking in
Zuckerberg is like what are you is that
English was that last question English
but it is true by the way they have a an
actual process by which they deem
somebody a fact checker on Facebook and
as for the quote/unquote ties to white
supremacy that she's referring to a
couple of low-level writers for the
Daily Caller who ended up being fired
after old facebook posts came out from
like ten years ago or five years ago or
whatever it was the Daily Caller does
not have documented ties to white
supremacist groups that's insane that's
insane that's like saying that that
James Hodgkinson who is the the mass
shooter of Republican Congress people
was a member of the Bernie campaign and
therefore Bernie has ties to mass
shootings like that's that's just
bizarre and crazy but this is Democrats
want control of the methods of do of
dissemination of information they made
that perfectly clear to to Zuckerberg
like what do they understand what
Facebook is for so they they were
attacking Zuckerberg over Facebook and
they were attacking Zuckerberg over the
creation of Libre which is basically a
Bitcoin thing right and Bitcoin in my
opinion is generally a good I like the
idea of people being able to barter and
exchange using a currency that is not
under the control of a centralized
government I don't like the idea that
the United States government can simply
devalue their currency whenever they
it's bizarre to me so all these Congress
people were attacking Libra and they
were attacking Facebook but doing so in
like the weirdest possible way in the
most bizarre possible way so take for
example do we have this clip of Maxine
Waters talking about misinformation so
Maxine Maxine Waters questions uh Coburg
and she asked specifically about whether
Zuckerberg was putting out
misinformation in a oh she did the same
thing like well are you willing to put
out campaign ads that have overt lies in
them and Zuckerberg is like well not if
they're suppressing votes right I mean
that has an actual impact but it's not
our job to evaluate for our readers
true and false coming from prominent
politicians that's their job that like
more information is better and Maxine
Waters can't handle it because Maxine
Waters is not a logical human being
Facebook itself actually does not check
it does not fact check what we do is we
have feedback that but people in our
community don't want to see viral hoaxes
or or kind of wide that may be clear you
do no fact-checking on any ads is that
correct
chairwoman what we do is we work with a
set of independent fact checkers who
somebody that checks on ads you have you
contract with someone to do that is that
right
chairwoman yes and tell me who is it
that they bag checked on I mean she's
just saying nonsensical questions she's
conflating everything right there the
policy of Facebook is that when
politicians put out as they do not fact
check the ads for taking down because
they feel the fact checkers are then
going to fact check those ads when it
comes to people putting out you know
direct attacks on on people that are not
politicians right when it comes to
political speech in other words Facebook
takes a pretty broad view when it comes
to supposedly when it comes to you know
an advertiser who is advertising a
product and they're slandering somebody
then Facebook won't put that up that
seems fairly clear but these people
don't understand even like the basics of
how Facebook works why because they just
decided that big tech is the bad guy
unless they can control big tech like
listen to what they actually want here
are some of the Dumber those were the
more intelligent questions believe it or
not you ready for this one here's Al
Green representative Al Green and he
believes from New York asking how many
LGBT people work on the Bitcoin Libre
like what
what what is it that's like saying how
many gay people work at the United
States Mint like what does that have to
do with anything like would it make the
US dollar less legitimate if there are
fewer than 3% of the people who work on
the US dollar are gay be like what what
here's green being at being a complete
one would assume that you would
know who heads these corporations that
are going to be running this global
company how many of them are minorities
mr. Zuckerberg congressman I I do not
know off the top of my head are there
any members of the lgbtq+ community in
the associated with this association mr.
Zuckerberg what hold up hold up El Greco
how many transgender people are working
on Libre like you're getting called in
front of Congress
I feel like Congress may have
overstepped his boundaries just a little
bit and listen I don't trust dr. Berg
and I don't trust anybody even listen
trust anybody I don't trust anybody in
big tech to keep to their promises but
Zuckerberg is at least articulated a
standard you think I trust Al Green who
is questioning whether Libre should be
able to go forward based on how many
people who believe they're a member of
the opposite sex are working on the tech
for Libre but what in it's it's it's
insanity you want those people in charge
of the country you want Elizabeth Warren
in charge of the country you want you
want those folks I don't I know okay
time for some quick things that I hate
there is a poll out about Jewish
Americans apparently nearly 1/3 of
Jewish Americans say they have hidden
their religious identity or avoided
carrying items that would identify
oneself as Jewish in public due to
threats of anti-semitism according to a
poll released by the American Jewish
Committee
apparently 31% of respondents said they
had avoided publicly wearing a carrying
or displaying things that might help
people identify them as a Jew I mean
frankly you know look I I wear a keep up
everywhere yeah I in the United States I
feel very very safe as a Jew there are
certain areas where if I'm walking
around I am probably gonna wear a
baseball cap because I feel like they're
less safe for Jews that is not any great
shock and that is why among other
reasons Jerusalem
we are broadcasting from manners and the
fact is that anti-semitism is a deep
part of world thought the fact is that
Jew hatred tends to crop up incredibly
regularly we are not yet two generations
removed from a Holocaust the fact is
that anti-semitism crops up everywhere
from Williamsburg New York to the halls
of white supremacists in in Washington
state like this is this is a real thing
and that's why a State of Israel that
defends Jews that is a place where Jews
can go if things get rough is is a very
very important thing I will also point
out that I am I'm quite amused by Ilhan
Omar who's in over dance I sent my
Tomino Ilhan Omar hates Jews she hates
the State of Israel which are not quite
the same thing but tend to be heavily
related not everybody who is anti-israel
is anti-semitic but everybody who sounds
somatic is anti-israel I've yet to meet
an anti-semite who's really really
pro-israel just is not a thing that
exists in any case Eloheinu Omar had a
piece today called sanctions are part of
a failed foreign policy playbook stop
relying on them and she made the case
that the United States should not put
sanctions on Turkey
even though Turkey ran roughshod over
the Kurds the United States should not
involve itself in sanctions she says in
so much of our foreign policy we rely on
muscle memory and a limited toolbox to
decide the best course of action
too often sanctions regimes are
ill-considered incoherent and
counterproductive except for the Jews
ready go hon omar is totally fine with
everybody on earth including states
boycotting the jewish states the only
democracy in the Middle East but if
you're going to if you suggest you're
gonna put economic sanctions on Islamic
dictatorship in Turkey that just bombed
the living daylights out of the Kurds
that Ilhan Omar is very much against
that that is very she also says we
should not have sanctions on Venezuela
where people have been relegated to
eating their household pets because
everybody is starving in Venezuela
thanks to socialism she says that we
should not put sanctions on Venezuela or
Iran she says we should not have
sanctions on Iran either she says that
sanctions have simultaneously
strengthened the Iranian regime's
credibility at home and United human
rights activists and the Iran leadership
in opposition to the strategy if you're
a human rights activist and you're very
very Pro Ron in their fight against the
sanctions you're not very much of a
human rights activist but so just
to get this straight no sanctions on
Venezuela
no sanctions on Iran no sanctions on
Turkey divestment boycott and sanctions
against Israel right the last what are
the BDS is sanctions to on sanctions on
Jews but nobody else but don't worry
guys anti-semitism is totally dead
there's no reason for the State of
Israel to exist Jews don't need any
place to live because they're well
accepted everywhere obviously I mean
anti look
Ilhan omar is just against sanctions she
doesn't like sanctions for anybody
except people who wear funny hats and
have names ending in like Bauman steena
it's just that's not because she hates
those people it's just because those
people happen to be really greedy and
money-grubbing and because they're so
mean to people of other religions I mean
let's be straight about this right
they're hypnotizing the world but
anti-semitism is totally dead which is
why Israel should give up sovereignty
over Jerusalem and basically just you
know move off into the mists of history
Israel is no longer necessary say the
anti-semites who also hate Jews perfect
thank you thank you Oh hon Omar really
appreciate it okay you know what we've
done enough things that I hate today but
you know one more one more quick thing
that I hate so the media the president
Trump's lawyer is defending president
Trump today because because President
Trump is trying to defend himself
against attempts to go after his tax
returns well attorneys for President
Trump said that if President Trump shot
someone in the middle of Fifth Avenue
New York authorities could not punish
him while he's in office that's what the
president's lawyers argued and this was
treated as a grand revelation how could
how could you possibly say that if Trump
murdered someone on Fifth Avenue
he couldn't be prosecuted literally
everybody believes this okay this is
well-established well established
jurisprudence in the United States the
President of the United States is not
subject to state criminal sanctions
while he is in office if Trump were to
shoot somebody on Fifth Avenue
he would have to be impeached why
because what you don't want is 50 state
attorney generals prosecuting the
President of the United States while he
is in office which is exactly what would
happen but this is being treated as a
great revelation by the media because
the media obviously have a dog in this
particular fight okay we'll be back here
tomorrow from a less beautiful location
otherwise you can join us a little bit
later today for two additional hours
from this beautiful location I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Serling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director pavel white house key
edited by adam sy events audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
after weeks of closed-door Democratic
impeachment meetings congressman Matt
gates leads a group of Republicans to
storm the secretive deposition room to
demand transparency meanwhile a top aide
to Hillary Clinton signals that
America's favorite battle axe may be
running again some fear the u.s. is
headed towards civil war I fear a far
more dreadful future we are becoming
Great Britain check it out on the
Michael Nolt show
[Music]